good morning John I am currently living
in the hotel and will be for the next
two weeks but in order to celebrate the
glory about whatever the world is I'm
gonna tell you 50 öre jokes and the next
four minutes three termites walk into a
bar and say the bartender here what do
you go a boomerang that doesn't come
back I think you would call that a stick
what's the difference really between
kinky and perverted kinky is when you
use a feather perverted is when you use
the whole chicken Oh Billy why did you
eat your homework teacher tile the roof
of cake what do vampire zombies say hey
how come I nose can never be 12 inches
long because then it would be a foot
what do punk-rock Pirates use to open
doors on our key why doesn't Julius
Caesar ever use his cell phone because
he's dead Mickey Mouse is in divorce
court and the judge says so you want to
divorce your wife because she's crazy
and Mickey says oh no I think what
you've heard me say is that she's been
goofy how many eighteen-year-olds does
it take to screw in a light bulb
well just two but you have to have a
pretty big light bulb to fit him in
there
the calendars days are numbered did you
know that Michael Jordan can jump higher
than your house yeah my house can't jump
at all today hair change delightful and
then I crossed the road and then I
walked into a bar and I realized that my
entire life is a joke a rubberband
pistol was confiscated in an algebra
class the other day it was a weapon of
mass disruption they say celebrities die
in threes Ed McMahon Farrah Fawcett
Michael Jackson Beavis at Billy Mays to
throw in the 4th for free
why didn't Mary Poppins have to buy
tissues in bulk because of the super new
infectious strain of chronic runny nose
is I was wondering why the frisbee was
getting bigger and then it hit me how
many elephants can you fit in a Mini
Cooper for two in the front two in the
back
how many giraffes can you fit in a Mini
Cooper none cuz there's already all
those elephants in there how do you get
two whales in a Mini Cooper ah same way
you get two whales in any other car you
get on the m4 and you go across the
Severn Bridge how do you know that
there's an elephant in your refrigerator
you can see the footprints in the butter
how do you know if there's two elephants
in your refrigerator you can hear them
giggle when the light goes out how do
you know if there are three elephants in
your refrigerator cuz you can't quite
get the door closed how do you know if
there are four elephants in your
refrigerator cuz there's a Mini Cooper
parked outside
what's grey has four legs in a trunk um
Mouse going on vacation how do you make
Lady Gaga cry pokerface why are
elephants
gray and wrinkly because if they were
small white and hard they would be
aspirin what is the difference between
an elephant and a plum plums are purple
what did Jane say when she saw a herd of
elephants coming over the hill look well
herd of elephants coming over the hill
and what a Tarzan state when he saw a
look a herd of plums come over the hill
and maybe you forgot to mention that
Tarzan is colorblind what's brown it
rhymes with snoop up dr. Dre if quizzes
make you quizzical what does a test make
you not not who is there
ether ether who ether bunny knock knock
who's there
nothing nothing nothing bunny knock
knock who's there
Stella Stella who Stella mother Easter
Bunny knock knock who is the hare cargo
o cargo hoo gargle beep-beep and run
over all of those ether bunnies yay how
many Dragon Ball Z characters does it
take to change light bulb over 9000
Beethoven and Mozart turn into when they
died decomposers what is a chicken's
favorite composer awk
what did the stamp say to the envelope
stick with me man we'll go places what
are you feeding invisible cats
evaporated milk today I was reading the
newspaper and I saw this horrible study
about all the dangers of drinking it
scared the crap out of me so that's it
from this day forward no more reading
what did the wicked chicken lay a
deviled egg doctor doctor I slowed down
my pen what do I do use a pencil one how
many mind reader's does it take to
change a lightbulb
what what wait a second how many
computer programmers does it take to
take a light bulb
yeah none that's that's a hardware
problem what do you call a deer with no
eyes no idea what do you call a fish
with no eyes Oh what starts with that
ends in uck and usually means excitement
a firetruck what starts with P and ends
in ORN popcorn 50 jokes in four minutes
if you want more there two more of these
videos links are here
I'm totally singing Charlie's song I
stole it from his truth to fail Duke to
do